all right we are back on our 150th
episode we're talking about various
space conspiracies yeah now on this
segment I kind of want to get a little
bit into flat earth stuff finer stuff
because I could not believe that there
were still people in this day and age
that genuinely believed that the earth
was flat I thought we had left that
behind his thousands of years ago but
apparently we have not because there are
actually people nowadays that believe
that the earth is flat now you said
before you don't rank yeah you talk
about flatters reality yes so people
want to call it Flat Earth theory it's
not a theory it's a reality but but it's
a it's a it's it's different kind of
reality than you're used to the reality
that isn't real that kind of money
people want to believe that the earth is
flat because it's biblical
in nature's religion most of the people
want to believe it but there are other
people that want to believe that the
earth is flat is like people like me ok
I'm flattered is realist I want to bring
to earth this flat because it's more
challenging in what sense well it's easy
to prove that the earth is round man
[ __ ] you're a bad you got to be a bad
[ __ ] if you can prove Wow
all right well I have yet to see anyone
I prove this flat you will we get yeah I
was in an airplane and I proved it was
flat because look if you're on a sphere
alright and you're in an airplane flying
around a sphere okay and you're flying
straight okay here's the sphere right
you would fly off of it like that and
leave the earth behind okay no talk
about just what cuz you're flying
straight okay but so if you get on an
airplane
alright and you little the little the
little uh a little lunch tray that comes
down on the back of the the yeah the
cart cart you know well you know the
seat in front he's got you got a
got a table on it uh-huh lower that
table okay and you put a level on that
okay oh you saw that YouTube video yeah
you put a level on that he proved it he
put out he didn't prove it but I put a
level on that right you'll see that that
plane isn't going down to hug the
curvature of the earth it's going
straight it's flat hey like I'm apples
I've heard that I've heard that that was
one YouTube video that was it was I
don't know how famous it was but I read
about it like on a refutation site that
repeated it and um yeah they mentioned
it I didn't watch it now you know I
don't want to you want to you want to
bring up all this gravity and spheres
and fears have gravity and mass that's
fine that's easy explanation it's just
there's this is a certain challenge to
proving that the earth is actually flat
do you think that's why they're in it as
for like a you'd be serious some people
believe that the earth is flat because
they try to make the earth flat because
that's kinda what's being described in
Genesis that it's flat it has flat
corners and those corners stand on
pillars pillars of the earth
yeah they're biblical literalism right I
didn't say what the pillars are [ __ ]
standing on turtles turtles it didn't
say anything about turtles I just said
that big pillars okay no stack a turtle
so that's the reason why they want to
say it's flat
other people are want to say that it's
flat because it's kind of a it's fun to
try to come up with crazy ways of
proving that the earth is actually flat
I would hope that because like I said I
don't know I was reading this article it
was it came out in Newsweek about it it
was probably about a year ago and it was
written by um Lee MacIntyre he was a
philosopher of science and I brought
some of his other stuff as well and he
went to a flat earth convention that
took place in I believe it was in Denver
Colorado last year in 2018 and he was
talking about because I think he was
kind of hoping to that some of these
people were just like
having people on or whatever but he's
like no mostly food more serious it was
about 600 people there so not like a
huge amount of people or anything but he
said now 99.9% of them were
fundamentalist Christians so it was
biblical literalism mainly he's like but
there were a few notable exceptions most
of the people who actually believe it
believe it because they're biblical
literalists yeah but I think there are
some other people that believe it too
and maybe some people believe it just
for like we said like as an intellectual
exercise in the sense that they don't
really believe that it's true they just
trying to prove this true but they just
find it entertaining to prove that is
true right just like have you seen their
models of that explain day and night and
seasons I mean that the earth is
actually flat the Sun is moving in an
ellipse around over the top of yeah I
see with the moon following it this is
what I said I don't know a lot about
this because like I said I I heard the
the thing that like flatter belief was
on the rise it's not like it's endemic
or anything like that it's like oh we
got like 200 more people than last year
so it's not like a huge amount of people
it's still a tiny percentage but I had
still been hearing about how planets
[ __ ] was kind of like increasing so I
was like kind of curious is like are
these people serious come on now
so I kind of like looked into a little a
little bit so I wanted to see like what
some of their models were and I was like
what do they actually believe like what
do they believe this [ __ ] looks like
gotta cut some backflips to get that
bottle to work you got to be as well yes
that's what I'm saying it's like okay so
essentially and there's differences in
what some of them believe and like I
said a lot of them get it from biblical
literalism or from literalism in the
Koran because there are some Islamic
flat-earthers as well but basically
their model is that yeah the earth is
like a flat sphere and that the you know
it has like the little Arctic Circle is
in the middle and then like all the
continents on the outside and then on
the rim is a wall a hundred and fifty
foot wall of impenetrable ice which
keeps you from going off the edge
and what's past the edge they don't say
the Islamic what's underneath
they don't say rocks Tomic model of
flattery is that the Sun that the earth
is flat and the Sun sets into a muddy
hole like a well yeah where black people
take care of it like the pit crew to the
Sun and then it comes back up
you don't believe if you don't believe
me horrible black people are the sons
pit crew that's some [ __ ] huh
and if you don't believe me I want some
of this [ __ ] they're smokin if you don't
believe me on you there's an Iraqi guy
the name of the channels called the
masked
the masked Arab and he does videos on
all on the Quran and he talks about this
surah he talks about it both in English
and in Arabic because he's bilingual and
he will explain to you exactly what flat
earth the food and with with Africans as
the pit crew to the Sun and also put new
spark plugs in that [ __ ]
man every 3,000 miles there is also
something about what's-his-name not keen
that David not not Moses oh the Greek
guy who conquered the earth Alexander
yeah
yeah evidently Alexander had found out
where it rose which I guess was India
you have to read your guesses get to
revisit those sewers directly to go see
the masked Arab yeah so I was seeing
this one I saw this one where does the
Sun set the name of the video yeah see
because when I was looking into like the
kind of American and British flat
earthers because it does seem to be a
mostly American and British phenomenon
you know I wanted to see like their
little models it's like well where do
they think that the Sun goes where do
the stars go blah blah so like I said
they think that there's like flat and
it's like ice around
all the outside perimeter that you can't
get through so you know there's no and
also some of them also posit that people
from NASA are guarding the ice wall to
keep people from climbing over it and
figuring out what's on the other side so
okay I don't know how that works but
what they have going on they also think
that the Sun and the moon are like much
smaller than there are in reality maybe
like thirty two miles across something
like that and that they're not that far
away and that they're just kind of like
above us a little bit and though there's
kind of like scooting around a little
[ __ ] circular whatever they're
actually installed into the fundament
yes look at the sky fundament that one
is meticulous Kyle that's the ceiling of
the sky I know the stars in the moon in
the Sun yes some of them also posit like
a dome over the whole thing so we're
like living inside like one of those
like our little Christmas shaker balls
that have like this now this is all of
course the only living inside of one of
those this is all of course the ancient
Egyptian model we had with the Duat and
which is and the underworld and the Duat
which is the horizon that was very
mystical to the ancient Egyptians and
that you know the stars and the Sun and
the moon were all set in the foundation
of the sky and there was a big
procession to went through so really
it's like throwing a pencil every
happens and Abrahamic religions are all
set in the Egyptian Universal bomb yeah
that's that's well the ancient Greeks
figured this [ __ ] they figured out the
world around him would like 240 BC
something like that
Eratosthenes figured that [ __ ] out yeah
we have just city folks baby folks also
I was reading some today it's like I
know that it's very um I don't know if
this is this widespread of myth as it
used to be but that like in the days you
know when Columbus was sailing around
exploring and [ __ ] like that
that everybody thought the world was
flat it's like most people did not think
the world was flat no they thought it
was round before I knew about they know
it was round back then they said the
only problem with the Columbus thing was
that they knew the world was round but
they didn't realize that it was as big
as it was
and also they didn't know the Americas
were there they said that was the issue
it wasn't that they thought it was flat
and people knew about
err thought about aliens for a long long
time oh yeah that goes way back
well [ __ ] what did what is what who was
the Omni burn one guy at the stake cuz
yeah that's he was not only talking
about aliens but he was talking about I
mean he was talking about like other
planets with alien civilization yeah
knows a fifteen hundred's forty niners
yeah something like that he was like
yeah I had a book about that gonna kill
his ass to say with you they did
announce it yeah but he wasn't the only
one that believed that yeah it wasn't
it's not as modern a concept no I'm not
this [ __ ] about well they're
protecting us from the UFOs because
humanity mankind can't handle it
that's [ __ ] too cos in the eighteen
hundreds the average person believes
that there were Martians on Mars yeah
Lowell and Hubble and all those guys and
I feel like they were the idea there was
a civilization on Mars and because they
kept seeing canals which is an optical
illusion but yep seeing canals on Mars
so the whole HG Wells things and
Martians come they knew that whole well
not only an optical illusion but also a
mistranslation of that word yeah Canali
that means channels jam not canals yeah
he was talking he meant ravines yeah but
they did kind of seem to be moving and
they thought it was a an irrigation
system for a dying earth and [ __ ] if
they're dying then they might come here
thus War of the Worlds and HG Wells yeah
that's what 1890s thought might buy
something like that but have you gone to
somebody in the 1880s and talked about
extraterrestrials like oh the Martians
they you know yeah it wouldn't have been
weird at all that wasn't a weird and
like I said even go back to the Middle
Ages yeah I don't think it was that
weird maybe was a weirder concept than
it was like in the Victorian era but it
wasn't unheard of your honor and like I
said the ancient Greeks knew the world
was a sphere yeah or an oblate spheroid
if you want to be like all phantom right
but um you know they knew the world was
round because it's obvious like once you
start looking at it it's like obvious
that it is it's obvious that it's not
flat but so one thing that I saw so my
size don't work if it's flat well a lot
of things don't like it
so this interesting thing that I saw and
I saw this one
by this one guy and he's call I think
he's called greater sapien he has a
channel on YouTube and he kind of showed
like a little animation that I think he
got from like a flat earth website that
showed like how the little Sun like
moved around the thing and he's like
okay now can we all agree that he's like
whether you're a flat earther around
Earth or whatever you want to call it
he's like that the Sun moves about 15
degrees an hour like not exactly but
roughly and he's like and it moves 15
degrees per hour everywhere on earth
that only works if the planet is a
sphere because if the world was flat
which he showed very elegantly with this
model he's like check it out like if the
Sun is just going around this little
flat thing he's like if you were say
like right here in this little city when
this little dude was going like that
he's like then it wouldn't be 15 degrees
because it would be shorter yeah it
would be like it but yes LG Handa it
speeds up and it does like this with the
moon behind it it's doing all kind of
yeah yeah it's just lighting up a square
object it just seems like the mental
gymnastics that you would have to go to
and again this is another thing like the
Apollo moon landing hoax it seems like
this is something that you come to the
idea first and then you try to come up
with justifications for exactor which is
the spherical earth is for simpletons
the flat earth reality is for genius
advanced mind to understand Flat Earth
reality okay of how a son can speed up
and slow down how a moon can orbit
inside this over a flat surface bringing
light to the fall four corners of the
square yeah I know I have seen some like
kind of ancient belief system works or
where the earth was square yeah or like
kind of yeah it has like at corners in
it
sits on it stands on okay so I'm gonna
go with that there is a square I'm a
square everywhere
yeah it's not just flat square look and
like a like a checkerboard with
continents on it yeah okay
yeah Wow with a moon in it with a moon
and the Sun just racing around like
[ __ ] you okay so so has anybody done
the earth is shaped like a donut can I
be the first to do that
don't let earth that would in crawler
that would imply a dimension that
doesn't exist that well no I'm gonna
come up with all this kind of it I'm
gonna have a whole elaborate thing I'm
gonna have my own YouTube channel and do
all this I'm a troll you have to
understand you gotta incorporate the
fundament into all this and how the dome
of the fundament and the foundation how
it the middle of the donut is the
fundament because that's like the
fundamental like that's like the
butthole of the earth but then you have
si si you have to understand that you
can fall off the edge of the earth and
as you fall you would see the pillars no
that's because the sprinkles and the
frosting keep you from falling off the
edges just like the ice on the flat
earth one clearly the waters of the
earth mingled with the waters of the sky
that's why it falls it falls as rain is
certain circle it circulates yeah it
falls off the edge and then it comes
back to the earth in the form of rain
becomes the waters of the sky and the
earth that's why it's recycling the
water just like my mountains why the sky
is blue if you look at if you yeah if
you were to look at the ocean out you
know and then it goes to the very edge
and then it hits the end and it goes up
and it goes up inside the fundament and
then it falls stop saying that word it's
like it's every time you say fun to bed
it makes me think of a butthole you just
can't kind of keep me so no it's what it
says in what it says in Genesis I know
fundament he's putting the fun back in
fund the bedroom yeah yeah so the thing
about the flat earther like I said I
didn't think that any of these people
were serious but apparently some of them
are because here's a it's a okay if the
earth was flat not only would the whole
15 degrees through the Sun moving
15 degrees everywhere in the world which
it obviously does if you like stand out
there and [ __ ] watch it it's not only
would that not work but a bunch of other
[ __ ] wouldn't work either like mapmakers
with that wouldn't work it's like people
like the [ __ ] play like look I've
been in a plane you only have to go up
to about 35,000 feet you can see the
curvature of the earth from an airplane
it's an optical illusion pressure that's
the pressure that's what they say
actually they do say is it's refraction
or something like that in the light
which they come up with like some kind
of counting and it's hard to be a flat
earther it's very hard yeah are you your
Percy it take it takes takes it it's
easy to understand the spheres very hard
to understand something this flat okay
but here's the thing though if the world
really was flat yeah what would be the
point of making everyone think it was a
spear like what would be the point of
the conception what is the test your
faith it's the test your faith does that
what like dinosaurs dinosaurs were
placed in the earth by Satan to test my
belief yeah I've heard that no one
creationists again yeah in my experience
you know people that believe these kind
of things like to believe these kind of
things because it wouldn't it's making
you wrong yeah it makes you wrong yeah
so it's just wait it makes wait it makes
the person saying it wrong or makes
people argue against them now a flat
earther makes around earth or wrong they
just want to make other people wrong
yeah they're making other people wrong
but do they know guys right yeah they
know they're wrong
I kind of feel like they do that yeah
then I think it's like it's like a
warfare they're not gonna give that
victory out they're talking about yeah
in terms in terms of because you know I
I was a Christian I wasn't a
fundamentalist Christian I was raised as
a Christian and I understand the mindset
they don't they don't want a
non-believer to be right
they want their beliefs
be right also I think they get off on
being persecuted or they get off on
being um a perceiving that they're being
persecuted even if they have to like
make up that they're being persecuted
well I think everybody kind of does that
to a certain extent I mean you know you
have you know a lot of these a lot of
kids or a lot of college kids say that
they're persecuted a or not they're
obviously privileged they're in college
okay they don't know because they're
young they don't know anything well
religious people I think well it depends
on the religion some religions are
persecuted some of them are yeah like I
said I mean I think about it I mean I'm
Mississippi you know there's some he's
weird Mennonite cults and stuff yeah
they're kind of persecuted because
they're weird well I don't know if I'd
call it persecute me when I say
persecuted I mean you're like thrown in
jail and like orchard and stuff no
person it doesn't mean Oh people make
fun of you it's like people make fun of
you for all kinds of a variety of
reasons that doesn't mean that your
purchase being made fun of and being not
believed in isn't that was they perceive
that is that's what I mean to me that is
not that is not strong because they
don't give you their religion and you go
man I don't believe in that crazy [ __ ]
no sudden their feelings are hurt
they're like you persecuted me yeah see
that you're rejecting what I believe
you're rejecting the truth that's how
that's how they're gonna put it which
like I said if it was me like I'm not a
dumbass and like I don't go around
trying to like convince people of like
crazy religious beliefs but even if I
did like I would go to somebody's like I
would never do this this is an alternate
reality version of me I would go to
somebody's house and be like hey can I
tell you the word about the Flying
Spaghetti Monster or whatever and they
would say no [ __ ] off weirdo and then
I'd be like oh well more save salvation
for other people it's like I wouldn't
worry about it why they worried about it
what you just don't understand religion
and the way it is yeah I mean I guess
it's an evolutionary I do but I do but I
don't understanding you got mindset you
got gay people in religion going around
trying to defy other gays using the like
anti-gay therapy yeah like that it did
not get and then a few years later they
even even the ones
the therapy dropout and just says no
yeah because I can't do this anymore
right we saw that movie on it where you
had you know gay school anti-gay anti
gay church what was it called yeah I
can't remember whose name it was it was
a good movie that good movie about him
it wasn't it right yeah yeah yeah whose
base aren't you sir gay kid this root
who was in a religious family and they
sent him to gay camp through the pray
the Gateway can grant to pray the
Gateway and all the counselors there
pray in the Gateway we're all gay yeah
and they're like look we did it
yeah we're not gay within like the years
later they were like [ __ ] yeah and at
the end of the movie you find out what
happened all those people all those
counselors were gay there's two guys and
they just couldn't do it anymore because
they're because their whole foundation
like that was just undesirable why they
couldn't live a lie anymore
yeah and you know yeah I go on you to
hear people talking you know they're
from from California or New York you
know are places that city areas you know
they didn't have any capital religious
upbringing or any em religious influence
you know from their family because of
where they lived and it boggles their
mind you know I mean that a gay person
could be religious there's a lot of gay
people that boggle my mind it's just I
don't know like it's just something that
I wouldn't do because it doesn't make
any sense to me like if it makes sense
to other people that's you know whatever
that's up that's a little bit kind of a
mind it's kind of um kind of a mind
trick in the way that a lot of politics
is a mind trick because you know I you
know I see even the greats always said
that this is it this is a spectrum it's
like a continuum starts with
superstitions religions philosophies and
then politics in that order it's all
about the same thing their belief
systems things that you think are true
things that you want to be true for one
reason or another so you always gotta
got a question yourself you know what's
true no it's only true if you can
demonstrate it over and over again in
nature I guess you know well yeah that's
kind of where I'm coming from with that
there's a lot of politics that isn't
true that's why I'm kind of like that's
why I'm kind of like fascinated by these
flattered it's people because I'm like
if people genuinely believe
Eve and like I said these people are
kind of like analogous to like
creationists who like I said probably
pissed me off more than anything because
their biblical biblical literalists and
things creationism it's pretty much the
same thing it's like they read it in the
book so it's like it has to be true so
any kind of mental contortion they go to
to make it true is necessary so they
don't think about it as a mental
contortion I guess because a part of
fundamentalism yeah because if you can
come out and say well look this part
isn't true the Bible says the earth is
flat and that's not true
well that's not true then everything
else can be untrue a weird thing about
it is they don't want those chips to
fall they're trying to hold them all up
there as if it's yeah perfect belief
that there's no it's unassailable but
the thing is is that the Bible the New
Testament and Old Testament was never
like that
they were they were always there was
always a collection of works it had
always been harmonized in together it
was I never really supposed to be taking
that literally this is not a legal
system that's why that's why the that's
why the Muslims have the hadith you know
the hadith is the legal system part yet
I mean the because that's not the story
part the story part is the [ __ ] Quran
well the Christians don't have a hadith
so they try to make the New Testament a
high death in other words a legal system
and you can't do that it's just they're
just stories well I think - is that the
few verses that a lot of Fenneman
fundamentalist Christians point to you
as being evidence of Flat Earth don't
come out and say distinctly that the
earth is flat
it's an implication that you could read
into it if you were so inclined
but the Bible verses don't say hey Flat
Earth it doesn't say that it doesn't say
the earth isn't flat because you're
automatically supposed to be reading it
from the perspective that you already
know the earth is flat okay I'm just
saying what they the four winds the four
corners of the earth yeah but the thing
about that is that Jesus there's another
from heaven in the entire world I know
that means the device the whole four
corners thing they said the same four
corners thing using the same words to
talk about someone's head so unless
they're talking about someone's head
being square they're not implying that
the world is square or flat in that
first it is because it says it has a
fundament which is a dome a dome that's
over a flat earth that has star stars
Suns
a Sun and the moon is embedded in it so
there's a solid ceiling yeah I know yeah
so it's there and it moves the ceiling
moves that's the Egyptian model what
they're saying isn't new that's what
people even before the Christian era
believed well yeah one of the Jewish
here but like I said there's really no
excuse because the [ __ ] ancient
Greeks knew that the [ __ ] earth was
spherical so you think that they would
have yeah we think that was just one
place yeah man and you didn't have mass
media back then you know so every people
were skeptical of what foreigners
believed in and Greeks were just
foreigners you knows damn damn for
[ __ ] Florida sooner man and they did
weird [ __ ] you know with little boys and
stuff so why would you believe them
they've had rise
yeah that's yes so that's you have to
look at it from the point of view think
about okay now in those days there were
a lot of crazy beliefs there was no way
of today there's a lot of crazy in those
days there was no Riley know which ones
were correct yeah and you could try to
science the [ __ ] out of somebody who was
you know in in you know who is a
Christian in the year 400 and that might
not work but about it even today there
are people where science won't work on
them
well like it like I said might not even
like [ __ ] on people like 2,000 years
ago because they didn't know any better
people nowadays should know better and
yet do not that's kind of like what's a
turd well you're assuming that everyone
is of the same intelligence and science
shows over and over again that no that
IQ is a reality and that there is a
spectrum and inside IQ well obviously we
can't grasp certain concepts right there
I mean you know and then there's people
at the other end of the spectrum they're
like Einsteins and
you know who can grasp things that you
and I can barely imagine
although you got some [ __ ] wrong - yeah
there is some everyone does there are
some super geniuses out there at certain
end at the other end of the spectrum
that can imagine that make us look like
chimpanzees with the [ __ ] that they can
do in their head but I've nipped those
guys when I was you know down a Boston
in the MIT area because they're all
idiots of us so you don't hang around
whether they're well like I said there's
some there's some amount of trade off
it's almost kind of like well as soon as
they get that smart you don't want you
there did this woman's reign is a finite
organ yeah so if like a disproportionate
amount of it is like kind of put aside
for one particular thing then they
missing oh that is it for other things
that social skills like yeah like I said
or maybe um maybe it's not so much that
they didn't get that like genetically
but they thought it wasn't important so
they didn't really develop it yeah that
could be also you just can't stand to be
around them yeah grab to the Nerds okay
yeah like that yeah but then the thing
about it too is that I've known people
even in my own family that we're like
you know super geniuses and stuff like
that there were completely normal
individuals and you and I know so you
know what I mean it's it's kind of a
trade-off and like I said I I'm not
saying that that's not a cliché for a
reason but you can't like assume that
everyone there were other guys you know
especially you back in the 40s and the
50s that could didn't have any computers
but they could do math in their head
they did everything all this [ __ ] on a
slide roll and they smoke cigarettes
chase women and trying to [ __ ] knock
back shop yeah look at nice all-time get
Richard [ __ ] fine men yeah and that's
it look that [ __ ] was a sin and mother
[ __ ] to the moon and make an atomic
bomb yes yeah I mean so they were smart
but they were also Richard Fineman was
not a man to be trifled with it's kind
of like the the illustration of what
you're talking right it was actually
like kind of a genius level physicist
but but also operative soon hell yeah
and the closest you'd have been very
popular with women closest you'd have
that today would be Neil deGrasse I was
gonna say look and I was just gonna say
look at look like it could look at Carl
Sagan look at me on the grass
somehow Sagan was a shadow poon how that
dude right there the women loved him my
aunt we used to work with him he's super
foxy yeah Neil deGrasse Tyson I love
Neil deGrasse Tyson yeah well his
Twitter feed is Tyson Tyson carries
himself as a man that's a guy you can
actually have a trade he used to be a
wrestler yeah he wasn't like he didn't
like neglect he didn't realize other
aspects of other aspects yeah he's a
very well-rounded individual and he's a
good communicator so you know yeah he
just kind of like kind of look to the
whole thing but I can listen that dude
for hours I could - yeah you listen I'm
right I think I've read pretty much
every book he's ever written
it's but even that one about Pluto I
love that he got so much hate mail about
Pluto like when he devoted it well it
wasn't him that did it but I mean he
kind of advocated yeah we should demote
Pluto because if Pluto's a planet then
we have to like all these other like
many like dwarf planets we have to like
them make them planets - so let's not do
that
Tyson is today's version of saying yeah
that's why he got the cosmos show yeah
yeah definitely yeah Karl was the [ __ ] -
I sit back and listen to Karl talk all
the time oh yeah me too it's just that
you know a lot of his information is now
out of date now cuz they've discovered
so much more but a lot of stuff you said
on Cosmo turned out to be that yeah it
was verified a lot of stuff they said on
caught on the old cosmos well yeah like
well I think so it's not summer so it
was verified but I think they knew a lot
of stuff in the scientific community
that took a long time to like filter out
to the public well a lot ahead do with
exoplanets though they couldn't prove
that all those X's yes but they were
they sure yeah they pretty much knew
that all those damn stars and planets
and like I said I think that happens a
lot I think that scientists are like way
ahead of the curve yeah yeah you know in
making predictions and things like that
but sometimes they're waiting they're
like well we don't want to like releases
them until we have proof of it until we
know so sometimes it'll be years and
years then they'll be like oh okay
finally it was just kind of like you
know when they discover certain
particles or whatever it's like
theoretically they knew that particle
existed but they said let's wait until
we actually find you know repeatable
evidence of its existence before we go
out and tell everybody that it's there
nowadays you hear about
kind of cautious about nowadays I go on
here and here all these young young
young people that [ __ ] they're
pessimistic is [ __ ] about the earth you
know meaning environment like that man
I'm an optimist there are lots of
planets like this they're not that
unique we will be traveling to other
stars we will be we're gonna figure it
out mankind is not dumb I mean I hope we
do we're gonna figure that I'm in
realism I'm not an optimist or a
pessimist about it I just kind of like I
said you know what I'm just gonna see
what happens I'm just gonna roll with it
I wouldn't surprised me that in a couple
hundred years from now that will be a
will will be a multi-planet species if
not probably maybe multi star systems
because there might be a little trick
that we haven't really picked up yet to
where you can like bend space it's we're
gonna stumble onto some [ __ ] and it's
gonna be like oh is that all it is yeah
that's me next thing you know you got
like warp drive that's why I've always
said it's like I I find it and I might
have mentioned this before but I find it
pointless to like speculate about future
what's gonna happen in the future
because there are too many contingencies
yeah you don't know like if somebody
makes some like amazing discovery
tomorrow that people are like oh crap
why didn't we think of that before like
you said like finding space or it's just
for an example it's like so you know who
could have first seen for example the
impact of the internet nobody first saw
that know it's like so no one could have
predicted so I feel like it's kind of
pointless stupid days I think it's gonna
go this that way or that way no one
knows I hear these 18 and 20 year old
for 25 girls stressing the [ __ ] out over
[ __ ] [ __ ] like global warming and stuff
it's too [ __ ] early to worry about
that you don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on all you guys do is go back and
look at what they were worried about a
hundred years ago they were where do I
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] back in the 80s they
were worried about acid rain there was
really nothing to that okay [ __ ] will
work out I'm not worried well yeah it's
like that's kind of what I always like
like I'm not saying that bad [ __ ]
doesn't happen sometimes because it does
but it's like a workout if you have
done everything you can do to like
prevent a certain thing from happening
then that's all you can do and it's like
things rarely turn out as badly as they
think it's going as things you know you
know thankfully not always like
sometimes it turns out worse than you
thought but usually I think it doesn't
turn out quite as bad now I think that
sometimes that will one I think there is
a vested interest in making things sound
worse than they are
money's involved um you know just
because they like people being scared
and stressed out and stuff but also I
think there's kind of an aspect of you
know let's err on the side of caution
like maybe this isn't gonna be quite so
bad but maybe we'll just like say it's
gonna be bad just so we can get people
on board with doing this and that's fine
but it's like I don't think that things
turn out usually quite as bad as yeah
the problem I've been having recently
you know I build engines and I
understand her internal combustion and I
understand [ __ ] like jet engines and
things like things that actually work
you have these people stressing out
about fossil fuels and internal
combustion all right as if that's gonna
[ __ ] kill everybody
there's it there's got to be a certain
time scale involved and then if you
replace internal combustion which
eventually that will happen well that's
already out yeah eventually that'll
happen it's just that every form of
engine has some kind of an output
everything has some kind of a waste so
it's not so easy like for instance well
you're just trying to minimize you try
to minimize it that's just the best case
scenario what I'm getting at is this you
don't really have to eliminate internal
combustion what you have to do is you
have to make it very efficient and we're
doing that it's a lot more efficient now
than it used to be it's way better than
it was oh yeah even if even in the 70s
right a lot of it just had to do the
loss they would they would have forced
car manufacturers to make cars a certain
weight because they didn't want these
imports to come in that were ultralight
things that were kind of like four
wheeled motorcycles they didn't want
those on the road because corporations
were involved if you make a car
extremely light you can make it very
efficient you don't need to burn much
energy to get it to move
so because the hell are it is the more
inexpensive oh sure yeah so they worry
about [ __ ] there's other solutions for
nothing is June as you have electricity
but let's say you have to build you have
to have badass batteries for this those
batteries produce waste product -
there's a bunch of other factors it's
not you can't demonize one form of
energy you know over another you just
got to pick the best [ __ ] you got make
it very efficient and in my lifetime I
saw cars get way [ __ ] more efficient
much much better should have seen the
way they were in the seventies the 60s
50s huge v8 engines my ganti yeah huge
v8 Amanda burns all kinds of fuel that
even make 130 horsepower you know what I
mean remember those [ __ ] well yeah
and the minimum Scott yeah and the thing
about it too is that we were talking
about this the other day it's like
people talk about the good old days and
[ __ ] and I know I kind of harp on this a
lot but good old days it's like we were
alive in the set in the 60s and 70s and
the cars were enormous got horrible gas
mileage a lot of them didn't even have
seatbelts for Christ's sake you didn't
have to put seatbelts in them until
sometime in the 70s I think I'd have to
check but it's like you know much less
airbags or like all the other safety
[ __ ] we have nowadays [ __ ] nowadays is
so much better so much safer so much
lighter so much more efficient it's like
it's just way better now yes this way
the ultimate the ultimate and powers
going to be [ __ ] nuclear nuclear
power making good electric okay electric
motorcycles electric cars but to get
that done you have to have very quick
charging batteries and you can say oh
well that's terrible that you know there
are some people's in nuclear that's
dangerous what you can do with all that
[ __ ] waste blast that [ __ ] off into
outer space outer space is filled with
[ __ ] radioactive material blasted off
in outer space we've got all these
rockets that SpaceX Rockets if you
wanted to you could take all that
dangerous [ __ ] waste and just blast
it off in a deep space and wouldn't it
wouldn't be any problem because aliens
yeah well that's it well you don't have
to because space is highly radioactive
and very [ __ ] dead
to begin with there's neutron stars out
there it all kinds of [ __ ] weird as
material so blasting off some old
nuclear waste out there wouldn't even be
noticed in space it's just like we're a
B average [ __ ] yeah probably like I said
even if there were aliens he'd be like
oh well just that that's like nothing to
them so people worry too much
people worry too much but that humans
are smart they're much smarter than
people give them credit for
well some humans are smart these are
making money and they're making money
off of what they can make money off of
now and in the future new [ __ ] comes
down the pipeline just look at the
stupid [ __ ] they were doing 100 years or
50 years ago from now you know I try to
like sometimes I get pessimistic then
when you think about that's kind of how
I keep myself from going mental because
like you know I have anxiety and sheíll
I felt like everyone else but I'm just
like I think you know even 50 years ago
100 years ago look at all the stupid
[ __ ] people believe look at all the
stupid [ __ ] people did it's like we
don't do that [ __ ] anymore and that's
good
ninety years ago even though sometimes
it feels like you know two steps ahead
one step back but at least you're still
going ahead 90 years ago now even 90
years ago maybe eighty years ago they
were selling end energy drinks and the
active ingredient was what was it
iridium yeah or iridium something I
think yeah make a damn jaw fall off his
radioactive [ __ ] isotope that's what
I mean people back then just to make
like I said what was I saying that a day
it sounds like some short on RiffTrax or
whatever or it's like let's dry clean
our clothes and gasoline and try not to
blow ourselves up yeah to blow yourself
up housewife yeah although I touched on
it before the gasoline of those days is
like it's different sure by different
but it would still blow you up because
obviously they were making safety movies
about it yeah like tell your mom not to
blow herself up while she's dry cleaning
though buddy my old buddy Jimmy talking
about deep fried deep fried turkeys in
motor oil but that was old school motor
oil from like the [ __ ] 20s how
delicious it was [ __ ] you know what it's
like you know I say like that's weird
and stuff but like the more I think
about it I'm like you know
I'd probably eat it but can be said that
the oil wouldn't penetrate the batter
well yeah that's who thick I can dig
that and it would just kind of like
flash be like oil oil it was like it was
yeah I have [ __ ] chicken and he just
said it was that it was the best way to
ever fried chick it was an old-fashioned
motor oil oh my gosh one in a row yeah
not not used motor oil new motor oil
I was really yes'm I came out of an
engine I don't know why this reminded me
of that but it was just I guess cuz I
was just thinking about like old-timey
stuff that people would never do
nowadays yeah but you know back in the
old days I was reading a book about the
woman that was a subject of John Singer
Sargent John Singer Sargent painting
mathematics very famous painting and her
name was uh Amelie something I came from
what her last name was but I was reading
like a biography of her and she was like
this socialite and stuff and she was
like this you know very famous society
woman in all the like papers and
everything one of her main features that
everyone commented on was her beautiful
porcelain skin and the rumor was that
she got that porcelain skin by putting
just like arsenic or LED or like other
based you know that type of chemical
[ __ ] like on your face or even eating it
some of them would eat like little parts
of arsenic like to make you thinner and
like make you paler because that was
supposed to make you look more
aristocratic so there so people were not
averse to eating or putting like all
kinds of dangerous chemicals like on
their face or ingesting them or whatever
just because they thought it would make
them look better so it's like people do
that nowadays but I feel like not to the
extent yeah as they did back then you
know what I'm saying yeah and that's
just like that kind of reminded me of
that like how people would just like
slap [ __ ] David's just like eat
arsenic or put lead on their face or
whatever yeah it just like so it's like
oh I want to be beautiful and pale and
getting back to Angie though I'm a
double back on what I said the futures
electric you know and I'm a Motorhead
III like internal combined
motorcycles have build motorcycles cars
and but really when you're talking about
pound for pound dollar for dollar the
electric motors are [ __ ] powerful
they're strong and they're cheap and
they're simple you know you can put an
electric motor in each wheel or your
motorcycle
the weak point right now is the damn
battery they take too long and long the
charge they can hold a charge that it
take too long to charge that's the weak
point if we get a good batteries you
want to worry about fossil fuels if
you're worried about I'm not really
worried about it but if we can get those
batteries right you can have some
electric vehicles that would blow your
[ __ ] minds
well I feel like it's already going in
that direction it's just he's got to be
a situation where you plug that vehicle
in you can get charged within 10-15
minutes well yeah that's right you don't
want to sit there for hours waiting for
this thing but like I said I feel like
that's that's pretty obvious it's gotta
be pretty close sure and you know
electric stuff is better than internal
combustion once you get that damn
battery right yeah and that's got to be
common well yeah like I said I feel like
they're already making huge strides in
that direction which i think is like a
really good that's like a really
positive outcome even though I love
internal combustion motorcycles yeah I
love my Buell's and things like that
things that make noise and vibrate and
have it's that old-school shittim you
know those will always be there because
there are still vehicles over 100 years
old as classics you know Jay Leno's got
shit-ton oh yeah you could still drive
those they'll be around yeah yeah it's
just that really the way to go is
electric it's so much easier to fix you
know you don't need trees it's more
efficient yeah like so much yeah that's
really the weight of it and then you got
to think about the power plant that
makes the electricity that charges your
battery you want that to be nuclear
either fission or fusion ideally fusion
but I think fusions of ways away I mean
I just don't know I don't know about
they've been working on that for so long
yeah but you can get safe vision you
know the new power plants that have had
problems in the past like Chernobyl
everything that was human error and
there were old models you can make
really good fission reactors you know
today
yeah you know and then that would solve
the problem yes that's green at very
green you just boil in water and like I
said I feel like as time goes on even
though like I said in the short term it
does seem like you know things seem to
go backwards and stuff like that but I
feel like in the long term things are
kind of like moving ahead we're kind of
building on you know knowledge from
before and it's like we know what
mistakes we've made and we know how to
like correct for them so I feel like it
will be better I just you know what I
mean it's like I I'm not pessimistic
about the future generally I'm kind of
like um I'm gonna wait and see what
happens kind of person since the advent
of humanity technologies don't always
move forward yeah like I said sometimes
in fits and starts sometimes it went
backwards for a little while and then
not for long even but yeah usually even
the fall of the Roman Empire the
technology kept moving forward basically
even through the middle MIDI Middle Ages
is still kind of moved forward there are
a few things that were forgotten but you
know a lot of it had to do with medicine
and philosophy but steam power was
forgotten
yeah but they wasn't really needed much
either in the Middle Ages but but you
know we'll continue to progress yeah in
general I feel Algie technically I feel
like we're going in the right direction
I don't me you know what I mean I feel
like we've gone too far at this point to
kind of regress to like Dark Ages kind
of era I don't think that's ever gonna
happen well what was funny about the
dark ages the dark ages wasn't a
technological thing it was it was a
societal thing it was so we wasn't
completely wasn't it wasn't completely
dark dark yeah so we might go back into
a more we're gonna have savage area
savage eras they're gonna you know in
epics but the technology will still
continue to go now I believe if you
history is anything yeah I mean I do
feel like we've things just aren't
forgotten easily especially not nowadays
yeah I mean and I feel like nowadays we
have a better way of you know keeping a
record and and and because people
nowadays I think people forget
even the average person nowadays is
really like technologically and
scientifically savvy in a way that
people a couple hundred years ago just
work civilization could collapse and
there's nut machines laying around where
people to keep them running for another
50 60 years until they can figure
anything on their own and a lot of
people have the knowledge to know how to
run that to run what I mean so it's not
like cars machine guns generators
electricity that none of that stuff's
going anywhere
yeah that will all be known will be all
right textiles internet might go
somewhere but computers will probably
not go anywhere because there's a lot of
old computers sitting around and people
know how they work how they work right
that's what I mean it's like you can't
take away even though you might be able
to take away for a short time like the
actual technology itself but you can't
till we take away people's knowledge of
how it worked right and a lot of people
know how it works if it collapsed the
world would look kind of like
Afghanistan but Afghanistan has all
these things it has cell phones yeah it
has everything else do you want to hear
something that wouldn't take long for
word to actually start to pick back up
do you wanna hear something funny
I don't know why this just reminded me
of that but um when I was uh this was
many years ago when I married my
ex-husband and we were talking about
going to Wales because we lived over
there for a while my I guess it was my
stepdads mother she's passed away now
she asked if they had electricity in
Wales in the United Kingdom yeah in 2001
who I asked if they had electricity if
they had VCRs yeah if it I'm like where
do you think we are talking about this
is a bugger and in fact when I started
going to the UK in the 90s they had
ubiquitous cell phone use before the US
had it yeah everybody had a cell phone
over there way before we had one because
I remember going over there in the early
90s 94 95
everybody had a [ __ ] cell phone that
was way before people had cell phones
over here yeah so they were like ahead
of us in that regard
so I thought it was very funny that - I
mean she was super old like to be fair
but like she didn't even think they had
electricity or like enduring this
toilets or like you know video DVD
players or anything she didn't think
that any of that only thing the most
poorest malaria backwards countries on
the world right now
they have electrical power of course
yeah
I mean you'd have to be like really out
in the middle of nowhere yeah to not
have that stuff what do you think what
would be the most primitive country
right now you think well I don't know
Somalia probably but yeah but even there
you'd have out in the middle of nowhere
you'd have to be out in the middle of
nowhere to not have electricity not have
yeah Wi-Fi not have satellite it's like
you know I mean Somalia may not have
Wi-Fi maybe not yeah but it does seem
like it you have to be yeah you'd kind
of have to be out of the middle of
nowhere but I just thought it was very
funny that she thought a first world
country like the United Kingdom would
not have electricity or like video
players or things like that I thought
that was very funny it just goes to show
how people are like old people are kind
of goes back we're kind of out of it
well like I said this wasn't her last
like like early 2000s when I moved to
Brazil back in the 80s my grandmother
bag and damn Mississippi was surprised
to find out that Brazil was not a
backwards country yeah I feel like I
thought that it was in Africa I feel
like all day and like I feel like maybe
like I don't think my grandparents had
this so much but I do feel like there
was a perception among older people
particularly like in the 80s 90s maybe
early to that baby up until the early
2000s that any country other than
America like didn't have anything yeah
so like I said that when I when I came
back from the UK and said oh well they
have like all this [ __ ] that we didn't
even have like they had cell phones
before we had them they had shipped like
credit cards and ATM cards way before we
had them they had all this other kind of
stuff so like the fact that they could
not only like have that stuff would be
like several years ahead of us was like
that that just didn't even register
understand that at all they thought
everyone else must be just like a
backward nothing like nobody even like
everyone was using outhouses and there
was like [ __ ] in a hole outside I
don't know what they were thinking what
the [ __ ] is like what year was this like
I said it's like early 2000 dude that
was like early 2000 that's maybe late
90s but Alissa I thought it was very
funny but um it was she was she was
super Syrian ever we talked about these
go on that date I always think of like
the mid 80s back in like 80 or 85 any
Italian American Italian restaurant you
went to in a mall or in cut strip mall
always all had that same cheese and that
st. the same [ __ ] pizza the same
calzones remember that the same [ __ ]
meatballs it was like every Italian fad
for this place was the same place even
though they were all privately owned
well because they all got ya Cisco or
service it all tastes the same
everywhere mall had that damn same
restaurant even though that it was
privately owned by an individual guide
he thought he was the only one but no
dude your meatball subs tastes just like
everybody else's we do from Cisco again
my ex Essman used to work for us food
service which is the second largest food
supplier after Cisco yeah so he used to
tell me about like all the stuff they
said had in the in the warehouse and
stuff like that so pretty much every
chain restaurant get their stuff from
one of those two places yeah um you know
I'm not arguing about ones that are like
independently owned like they might get
their stuff from elsewhere but most of
your chain restaurants you know Chili's
or Red Lobster or whatever they usually
get all their stuff or most of their
stuff from those two places and it's
almost always frozen or boxed they all
hadn't seen that's why it always tastes
the same they all had that same skim
milk mozzarella cheese it was like glue
that's like um best most of the stuff
that you can buy in the supermarket
I mean yeah you can get the buffalo
mozzarella like it's Sam's and you can
get it like but it's very expensive it's
like what like seven bucks for like a
little I had cake I has it you know I've
had you know some European French you
know I was up in Boston they'd come down
you know they're from Germany and stuff
maybe this is back in the 90s and they'd
be mystified by the food that we had you
know like and it was [ __ ] like that
cheese don't like they don't have that
cheese they're not real food yeah and I
get that I got beer and [ __ ] they're
like man well this is some shitty beer
it's something that Europeans can't
fathom of how big the United States is
and these companies that make this [ __ ]
are supplying a [ __ ] huge country and
they're trying to keep the prices as
well as they can
yes they're trying to make it as shitty
as [ __ ] yeah so it's kind of like shitty
like this shitty like that it's cheap
but not shitty half the people playing
it not buy it so this stuff basically
like American World War two industrial
food factories yeah that could make
[ __ ] 20 tons of [ __ ] cheese a day
all right that's where that [ __ ] was
because it got to supply all these
people yeah so it would blow their minds
I mean we have these little we have the
whole breweries and local better now
yeah better now they're not it was
because now like people have an
appreciation and for like stuff that's
you know that that's made locally or
that's they didn't make my smaller Baby
Boomers didn't know food and their IRA I
think they had no taste and their
parents were even worse they were almost
like Soviet level you know they were
like Soviet level palates a boiled
potato was good to them a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] cabbage was good to them you
know I mean they would eat anything if I
could it was David good was what they
would call a smorgasbord oh yeah
it was the most blandest whitest food
just white people food on steroids it
was just like nothing it's salt on it
was salt don't study is salt on it we're
gonna eat the [ __ ] out of that stuff and
it was like it's in deeply
it's all something came out of factory
yeah I'm late you know what we should do
a whole other thing as I'm getting they
go less foreign food and I remember that
to you in like like I said if you guys
are younger you might never met I don't
like yeah you know I you know we grew up
in the 70s yeah so it's like I remember
when spaghetti and meatballs was like
what that was for infinity for food that
was for Isis weirdest Chinese food to
them yeah and like the only Chinese food
you could get back in the day was that
literature which I can look at out me
yeah they can chow mien yeah you'd have
that it was like some exotic [ __ ] man
it's like would have water just where
the [ __ ] these what is it water chest
yeah it was like these brow oh yeah it
was like it's super weird and like it
you know if you eat it now it's not
terrible you can eat it now a head [ __ ]
it's really bland it doesn't really
taste like real Chinese food right so
like I said it it's a horrible I could
still eat it if I had to but it doesn't
taste like it's fake that's dead in the
90s I'm [ __ ] embarrassed you know how
to have these [ __ ] German girls that
are [ __ ] in Boston I'm hanging out
with them and they're like they thought
the food is atrocious I'm trying to
explain to him that this is industrial
mass produced food
you know we had micro breweries that
made yeah the beer we had you know but
nowadays they're not more so yeah and it
was about national level
yeah now you can have national level big
food factories to where man it's hard to
tell that that's damn that didn't come
out of a [ __ ] food factory like
that's another way in which [ __ ] is a
lot better nowadays management and I'm
gonna give you credit to like hipsters
for this here because one they love beer
- they love all kind of like different
food so yeah I feel like the acceptance
of all this different kind of different
kind of beers that we're kind of food
and stuff like that I think that's
really like coming to the fore in this
and I think people like have a lot of
more appreciation now yeah the American
food is a lot better than used to be
what you can get I mean you get
everything
well yeah depending on where you live I
mean obviously if you live in like
fantastic Indian restaurants ash [ __ ]
Wisconsin or something you can't get
anything but I feel like it's a lot
better nowadays like we live in Orlando
Greek food you can I mean we can get
pretty much anything we want you know
whenever we want it it's like there's
tons of restaurants around here even if
you have to like drive like you know 10
15 minutes yeah 20 they got rid of all
the old chain now they have like new
yeah it's like what Red Robin and places
like that you know
weird stuff we didn't recognize we're
driving around well is that Jenny
you know well there's some chains to you
that have been like around cuz I think
Bret Robins been around forever but we
just got it yeah here like not that long
ago it's pretty good yeah for a burger
that's like it's not like the old chains
we grew up with
now food Wow long way yeah we're going
way off the way like I said people love
to [ __ ] we're not talking about the flat
earther [ __ ] drunk and I'm not
talking about a fire well like I said I
feel like you know what maybe we should
maybe this probably won't get that many
views but I feel like we should do a
whole show on like food history
yeah I'm fascinated by that kind of [ __ ]
like one of the main things and this is
like no joke one of the main things that
I read about is that I read about like
mid-century type recipes and like why
people cooked that type of way like I'm
really interested in like yeah like I'm
really interested in that kind of stuff
like why like particular food trends
like took hold at certain times and
stuff on it there's something about food
that ties into like culture in a way
that like I find really fascinating so
of that weird 60s food man
back I told you I buy I bought the book
it's like it's it's right over there so
it's like get that one that's right
under dr. sleep pull that out you pull
that out there's like a little book
that's right under that seaming just one
that so I get I bought this the other
day just cuz this is called and I
probably showed this before it the
amazing mackerel pudding plan these were
like recipe cards from the 70s and these
are magical you don't eat any of that
yeah these are from Weight Watchers if
any of you have gone to like any of the
blogs because there's a couple of them
and I can't move with the one that's
called it's like gallery of unfortunate
food or regrettable food that's what it
is but they have like the Weight
Watchers cards from the 70s it was like
a whole
pack of them I think my mom had them and
the photo says the food we're just like
look at this [ __ ] yeah they're like
they're horrifying and it's like why
wouldn't you want to eat this even it
wasn't supposed to be meat what's this a
meat loaves with horseradish
would you mean that [ __ ] I would never
leave yeah but I'm fascinated by that
kind of stuff it's fascinating to me
just it just frankfurter pie yeah from
in it I think my grandmother made that
command and I'm from an anthropological
viewpoint I am fascinated by this kind
of stay overnight stew and I'm look at
this [ __ ] oh boy that's American food
there's a couple that are like quote
unquote ethnic food that'll definitely
pop cabbage looks normal
some of them like normal but not many
yeah 60s and 70s but yeah those are like
Weight Watchers diet cards from the 70s
and it's [ __ ] priceless but I'm like
fascinated by that kind of stuff I don't
know how we got on this from light
talking about flat first for whatever
should we get back to earth yet earth is
not really flat but some people like to
argue this flat because its orbit it is
not like look if the earth was flat you
would think that if you have like a
super good telescope yeah that you could
go out with your telescope in the
backyard you could look through the
telescope and I can see [ __ ] Africa
from here if you get mad direction you
would think yeah yeah if you look for
the right direction you would what else
is cool how long has this been going on
for four flat earth an hour an hour's
time to actually
but I can't see Africa through a
telescope no which is why I think that
well I mean the real the whole reason
that the ancient Greeks the well the
first reason they thought about this why
they thought there was fear achill was
because they noticed that ships going
over the horizon they're like why do
they disappear like it looks like
they're going off inside of a ball so
they noticed and they were like oh I
wonder if it that means the earth is a
ball and then they figured out that well
there's much a mathematical [ __ ] compute
that - yeah and the whole thing about
anyway like lunar eclipses like because
that's the earth shadow go they were
already predicting the diameter of the
the circumference of the earth and the
Sun yeah like I said I mean the distance
between the two did a tall figure dude
did the diameter of the earth that was I
don't even remember them that might have
been 240 BC and yeah wasn't that far off
right so if he was he was just let me -
by the tools that he had yeah exactly
things like shadows and look exactly and
that was the same kind of thing as like
I said in Columbus's day was smarter
than you think they are exactly and she
back then they didn't have all these
other distractions they didn't have like
[ __ ] Netflix or like cell phones or
anything like that so they were just
like observing things there was a whole
subculture of dudes in these white
tunics man then thought about [ __ ] they
were called like wise man yeah so first
the first philosophers and scientists
and that's what they did they got famous
yeah I'm talking [ __ ] trying to finish
it out and then arguing over it going
Greek Hellenistic Greek stuff yeah well
I mean you have to like give props to
the ancient Greeks they figured out a
bunch of [ __ ] yeah that they couldn't
figure out state women boys though
that's part I don't understand
yeah but you know everyone knew that's
part of their culture a bunch of others
I think I'd have figured that out real
quick
yeah they were they didn't like women
they liked these boys I couldn't
understand well I guess they liked women
too because they didn't die out so
obviously they loved her they can trim
it down like cattle they were like
breeding pods really but they were all
of one else's name boys really what else
is the what the wife was just a maid
really what else is new I wasn't gonna
work in today they were not made yet
well made this work into a look at us
now yes I do I do most of the cooking
and almost all the cleaning you don't
tell the cleaner we talk about vacuum up
all the floors and [ __ ] and you might
have the kitchen in that day what kit
now I do the laundry I cleanse my hands
I do that - mmm
I do that - one time this is funny one
time I asked him I was like I was like
oh I need to clean the bathrooms because
I think someone was coming over or
something I only clean on someone's
coming over pretty much but yeah so I
was like yeah I've to clean and we have
like a big it's like one of those big
bodies has like a tub and a shower and
like two sinks and liked a little
separate whatever so he said that he
cleaned the bathroom yeah and I went in
there and I'm like this doesn't look
like it was clean it turned out that all
I did was clean the toilet that was in
the little bitty closet he didn't clean
no thanks he didn't clean the shower or
the tub I didn't claim that though or
the counter I didn't claim that though I
didn't find I thought you meant because
what I say clean the bathroom I mean
clean the whole bathroom area I don't
mean just clean the toilet if I said I'm
just gonna clean the toilet I would just
say I'm gonna clean the toilet that's
your mistake you misunderstood what I'm
saying bathroom means the whole bathroom
toilet means just the toilet okay it's
only good no we got it done eventually
yeah but yes so okay
but yeah I'm seriously I'm the one that
works though that's why I'm sick because
I'm just like working and working all
right we didn't even talk that much
about Flat Earth but whatever flat earth
is [ __ ] stupid and if you believe it
you're [ __ ] stupid yeah
can I say that yeah
yeah you can I can say that yeah it's
not flat is route obviously it's a
sphere it's like seriously how does
moody do you have to be a poly way
lighting is bad like him you know what I
mean it's like if you believe that this
foot I'm not even mad I'm gonna even mad
at you if you if you believe the earth
is flat because I think that you clearly
have some mental deficiency the earth is
[ __ ] spherical well like it is it's
kind of more as Neil deGrasse Tyson
would say they're actually kind of more
pear-shape okay slightly pear-shaped
flat earth reality is only like for
certain people and it's an exercise it's
a philosophical exercise that's not a
real it's not the kind of react it's a
metaphysical of reality right well the
philosophical riah that's kind of how I
try to look at this yeah because in a
lot of ways I'm a very rational person
like I said and I don't know if you saw
the show where I said that I'm Spock and
he's Kirk but it that's pretty accurate
yeah so I'm very Spock like so people
that are like have these weird like
irrational kind of viewpoints it's like
it kind of makes me angry but it's like
I know there's nothing I can do about it
so I just kind of get try to get over it
but this I don't know I just a lot of
people that there's a lot of people that
this that defend ideas that they know
are wrong yeah like I can see what they
call back in the day a pissing match
yeah you're in a pissing match with you
they know that it's wrong but they're
just trying to defeat you yeah that's
all it is well I don't take you
seriously I try to think to myself it's
like in a way it's good to think about
these types of things or try to refute
these types of things because it can
make you kind of like maybe even like
look into your own biases and like maybe
this is like how do I know the earth is
round and like maybe you'll learn
something that way so I try to look at
it in a positive way even though it
still kind of makes me mad but you know
certain arguments are not about
what's right and wrong some arguments
are just about [ __ ] you that's a bad
[ __ ] you well I know that that's what
they're doing but the thing about this
they don't wanna give up on they don't
want to give up on their belief the
thing about those kind of arguments is I
don't really have time for those steps
it's all games like if you like if you
genuinely believe that and here's
something that's kind of interesting too
that I wanted to get into a little bit
because I was reading this like I said
this Newsweek article that I mentioned
before those from my leave Lee MacIntyre
he went to a Flat Earth Society
convention and he was like the thing
that I noticed is that all the evidence
that they gave and stuff like that he's
like so I realized pretty early on in
the convention that any evidence that I
showed them he's like despite their
assertions that they wanted to hear the
evidence that the earth was round he's
like I knew that anything I presented to
them would just be dismissed or said it
was faked or whatever because flatters
Pleet people genuinely have said that
every single photograph that's been
taken from space like from the
International Space Station from the
shuttle whatever is fake it's been
thanked yeah which okay but so they
think every single one is fake so he's
like so I knew that that it would not be
productive to approach them from that
because he's like any evidence that I
presented would simply be he's like so
what I wanted to do was I wanted to get
to them from a reasoning standpoint he's
like so I the first thing I asked them
was what evidence would convince you
that you were wrong well they're gonna
say none that's what I mean he's like so
that seems to be the most productive
thing that I did because if they say
none then there is no point in talking
to them anymore because nothing that you
say is going to convince them that they
are wrong since why bother talking to
this is why the study of Flat Earth
realism is important because this same
effect
Trane's in Flat Earth realism and goes
into other discipline you're getting
into a scientific is like the whole
philosophical thing that's why this
thing treated me this
thinking goes into politics actly
academia actually it goes everywhere so
if you can understand or accept flatters
realism or flat or the flat earth
reality okay okay if you can understand
that then you can see how its beat that
this same distortion or the same okay
this same acceptance of Flat Earth
reality is happening in other
disciplines yeah I realize that yeah
that was the same argument that he was
people are doing this satirically yeah
so that this is happening everywhere
well yeah but that wasn't the point he
was making the point he was making is
that if you want to make any ground with
these people you have to first determine
if there's any point and trying to make
round with them because it's like is
there any evidence that you could show
that despite the fact that they say that
they want to see evidence of this on the
other is there any evidence you could
show them that will change their mind if
there is not then is there any point in
engaging them any further right we're
simply like abandoning them to their
decision yes which is essentially what
it is brilliant it's brilliant because
what's happening with Flat Earth
realists okay is that it is the same
phenomena that's happening in the room
politics and other parts of science and
social science and just everything news
people lie people lie people like to lie
and people like to win this is happening
everywhere you know just it well I'm
saying you ever been out saying that
everybody's a liar I'm just saying that
well in every subject there's somebody
in there that likes to lie well the
thing about it is that sometimes um and
I'm not saying that it's always
intentional but humans in general are
just they're hardwired to be a
particular way and a lot of people like
to believe in things that there is no
evidence for or that they only have
subjective evidence for for example
that's where
popular people have very people have
confirmation bias most people have that
so it's difficult to overcome biases
that are like inherent to the human
brain yeah that's good way to put it so
and not many people really do that now
many people really like kind of look at
themselves and be like you know why have
I come to believe what I believe you
know is there some kind of way that I
could have been mistaken about that or
so you know it's it's hard to look at
yourself in that way like that
objectively it's not it's not a very
natural some people just like to believe
things exactly if it's not sure they
stay you know comforting or whatever
right I think that's the main thing I
think that's the main thing I do think
that a lot of people come to their
beliefs well I'm not gonna say that
because it sounds condescending but I do
think a lot of people come to their
beliefs not just because they haven't
examined them you know what I mean they
do most people don't think of them from
an objective standpoint or from like a
standpoint of kind of coming away from
themselves and like looking at
themselves in an objective fashion I
think life is mostly about having fun
well a lot of people adopt these beliefs
because they they are fond to them and
they support the fun that they want yeah
maybe not fun in the sense that we would
understand right this [ __ ] that yeah
there and that this supports their
feelings of well-being and it supports
their viewpoint in the world yeah so
that this confirmation bias yeah this is
her this is what they've chosen to
believe that way well like I said I
think there's a lot of just religious
people you know no it's everything but
everybody's like that it's everything
like I said is very natural it's very
good yeah it's natural I'm light-hearted
about it yeah because I know a lot of
the stuff that I believe is true but
only to a certain point yeah only up to
a certain point there's always things
that can go outside of what I believe
that mean liked it yeah unexpected [ __ ]
happens I'm like oh okay alright well
that did happen
okay cool and I just keep on moving yeah
I'm not real rigid yeah I mean I don't
have certain expectations right you know
the problem is is when you get the
fundamentalists they have a bunch of
expectations yeah and fundamentalists
are in all disciplines they're even
outside of religion actually they're
their political fundamentalists I call
it that's it that's more dogmatism
dogmatic that's a good way of putting it
baby yeah dogmatic people you can't be
dogmatic well like I said it's it's
anything that any belief it doesn't have
to be a religious it could be anything
any belief that you come to for maybe
not completely reasonable reasons and
then later you just look for evidence
that supports but but you don't ever
look for any evidence that falsifies it
and I think that's a problem like I said
it's a problem but it's not a problem in
the sense that because it's a very
natural that's human the way our know
that's the way our brains work humans
don't pray it's something that has to be
overcome and that's hard and I
understand that a lot of people don't
want to do that humans are not pragmatic
and I learned this when I got out of the
Army and became a Salesman okay
emotions cells and emotions cells and
really when you look at money and the
billions of dollars that's happening in
stock market like in Wall Street and
everything really what's behind it is
emotion oh yeah people are buying and
selling is based upon how they feel yep
all right and really once you understand
that you really got a lot of the world
licked yeah yeah like that's like I said
that's not how reality works but that's
how human perception of really works
yeah yeah if you can understand that
people are basically more motivated by
by emotion they are yep and you can
manipulate those emotions then you can
get outcomes that you want and there's a
lot of people that are making the
[ __ ] [ __ ] on a body off that yep
politicians and leaders and that's what
they did
yep they understand people's emotions
and I don't think there's anything bad
about it just there's not part of the
human it's just part like I said I'm not
I'm not like making a judgment call
about it because I know that that's how
that's how human brains work that's how
they evolved to work yeah
it's just that we evolved in a
particular way that doesn't necessarily
reflect the way how reality is yeah but
like I said that's the pramatta failure
of our brain I'm a failure of reality
I'm a I'm gonna prove it in two words
mercedes banz okay mr. Benz yeah people
buy Mercedes Benz because of the emotion
okay people buy pretty much everything
yeah well other than like Mercedes Benz
making a lot of money off based off
because you need that Jenny and I we got
a Ford that we've run into the grounds
got 140 because I don't care about cars
that I will just buy something that's
Gia that gets me from we just spent very
little money on this [ __ ] car when
you really get down to it a Mercedes of
that same year couldn't have done that
now right Mercedes actually they have
expensive repair bills here there were
reality there the reliability in the
customer satisfaction her Mercedes is
really not that high
no the customer satisfaction the highest
customer satisfaction if you actually
look at the data is that little Korean
car what's it called look here no
Hyundai
Oh Hyundai Hyundai has the highest
customer satisfaction I know one of the
cheaper cars I know but that's my always
but little mercedes-benz a cell like
[ __ ] crazy and it's very [ __ ] pro
I would never buy one because it's
emotion but that exactly they want to be
seen in a certain way and they buy that
thing it's it's a status symbol and
right but another thing that I
understand because like I said I'm kind
of Spock like so I don't get this whole
thing is that other people do not care
what car you drive
yeah they don't really bassoon and they
do not notice your emotions that make
you buy that car my emotions but make me
but look at like what is the cheap or
tired that it's the most dependable
we're talking about the person I don't
care what it there talking about the
person that bought the Mercedes oh my
very motions this I'm just saying that's
what difference I look at a Mercedes and
go well if I should buy a Mercedes Benz
and what else would what would beat this
out really I'd probably get a Cadillac I
think probably a Cadillac
mechanically would beat out
mercedes-benz you know but just them
just saying I really have a Cadillac
like I said Michael today I like you
know my whole thing is what is the best
quality that I can get for the cheapest
price that is the only metric that I use
to judge that kind of thing I do not
care what other people will think about
my vehicle choice I do not care about
any of that stuff because I don't care
about other people's do you drive an old
man can't an old man's Cadillac into the
ground I learned to drive in several old
man Cadillacs and also my grandfather
had several of those parked in his back
yard along with several boats
he is a hoarder don't break really well
there wasn't much in them right in them
and they just yeah an old man's luxury
car yeah I know like I said I grew up in
that Jed I know yeah my my grandfather
had I believe three Catwoman's beige
will miss chocolate color and I don't
remember what the other color was but he
had several of them parts of the back
we're getting kind of drunk we talked
him enough about Flat Earth probably we
didn't talk much about it but whatever
this we got to what can we talk of me
there's not much to talk about with Flat
Earth really yeah it's not flatter than
flat like I said I like okay don't take
this the wrong way but if you believe
the earth is flat I'm thinking that
nobody listens to this show probably
please or not if you do believe there is
supplied you were [ __ ] [ __ ]
goodness and that'll mean that in a bad
way but go ahead and unsubscribe like
actually I don't even want to say that
because that's like an insult to
[ __ ] people go ahead now subscribe
that says that's how I feel about it
it's not like it you're like even your
your below creationists in my estimate
and that's pretty low because I I really
do not like I've met some creationists
though and but then when you got to talk
to him you find out that that they don't
really believe too firmly increase well
I don't even know her leaving firmly but
they were told that they were they've
never been and never really questioned
better a lot about it
that's the thing like if you start like
what like if you know something about
the topic because I found this as well
you know because I actually know how
evolution works I've like read a lot of
books on the subject so if you start
asking about specific aspects of
evolution what do you think about this
they get in you yeah they just get mad
or they don't know what you're so I feel
like a lot of their [ __ ] just comes from
like just being ignorant of how stuff
works or just being told that and just
buying it I don't know without DNA how
DNA works and epigenetics and selective
breeding and [ __ ] how you know I mean
well as soon as you start really getting
involved in the [ __ ] like animal
breeding or and you're dealing with
animals like in the horse business and
probably imagine probably the same thing
would happen if you're dealing with the
CIM sports medicine ok genes matter ok
and sports select winners ok based upon
their genes and their abilities you know
not just sports but nature nature is
kind of like a sport - if you keep
eliminating [ __ ] from the game
or nature based upon a certain criteria
certain genes will disappear no genes
will be reinforced yeah that's just all
this selective breeding yep that's what
we're talking about it's kind of funny
cuz the same people that don't believe
in evolution might believe in selective
breeding because it's almost kind of
like the same thing yeah it's like
almost like a smaller scale larger scale
but it's like they'll believe in [ __ ]
and the smaller scale but not on a
larger scale they don't like understand
that like you know smaller changes over
time will you know incrementally will
add up to like a larger change yeah I
don't get why they don't get that but
whatever I'm - yeah I've heard some of
these [ __ ] cows kids I can make weird
arguments based upon you are how you
feel kind of [ __ ] ideas no you're not
you know how you feel you are what you
are based upon your necessarily because
like I said and I think I've mentioned
this maybe on some of our serial killer
shows environment does play a very very
large factor it's it and it might be
fifty/fifty and i'm only saying that is
like kind of a pop psychology type of
thing but because nobody knows the exact
percentage but your genetics and the
environment
interact in particular ways and they
mirror back up home another so the two
can't really be separated but your
feelings don't make you six-foot-three
well no that's the deal and in nature
care there might be a situation where
nature would care if you were six foot
three yeah it doesn't care about your
feelings there are some things that can
be influenced by your environment and
some learners some things that can your
height is one of the things that are
genetically programmed and that their
sign your speed your strength well I'm
not saying there's nothing you can do
about that because somebody that was
born genetically predisposed to a
certain way maybe if they grew up like
let's say there were twins and they were
separated and one of them grew up in
like a really you know affluent kind of
family that had good nutrition and good
medical care stuff like that they might
end up taller than somebody that ended
up somewhere that had bad nutrition bad
new environment something like that
it's not going to be a huge difference
but it will be a difference so
environment does play a factor
how old-school dog breeders used to do
it is they'd have ford letters and dogs
okay that they could breed these four
litters together each one of these
litters might have had ten dogs in it
they choose the best dog from each one
of these [ __ ] four letters and they
kill all the rest of them and then they
just breed those four dogs together and
they keep doing that over and over again
to eventually gets the dogs that they
want that's [ __ ] cruel I could never
be a dog breeder but that's how they do
they would kill all those baby dogs well
and the one you know why I'm up with ya
but you know what though that's what
nature does nature kills all those dogs
but they just don't do it in infancy
they do it in adulthood as those don't
know about nature is that even if you
have if you have other attributes like
say you're not as awesome is like the
alpha dog but you're maybe a little bit
less but you don't still like breed a
little bit yeah
then your ship will still be passed on
so it's like there's more much more it's
not this cut and dry waiting for
variation there's more room for
variation dog breeders are only select
and based upon what that way look on
what they want what they want what they
look yeah and a lot of times what they
want is detrimental from what they see
because look what they did to like the
hug and things like that words like now
his nose is so brandy can't like really
make use anymore nature's show like the
nature is doing that same thing it's
just that it may be in a less stringent
what is this doing is instead of only
one dog surviving four dogs survive and
those four dogs survive for different
reasons
yeah so it's a little bit different
that's right eventually there's a wider
but eventually over millions of years
you have new dogs developed from that
eventually and that's just what we're
talking but as I said the thing about
dog breeders and pigeon breeders or
whatever you want to do is like
sometimes you're dealing with like
[ __ ] up like human conceptions of like
what they want a dog to look like like
hey I want a cat with like super short
legs wouldn't that be cute and then they
want to breed that right but that is
detrimental to the species it is yeah if
that was in nature cuz cats were done
that would die out so I feel like that's
not it's not a completely good analog
because you're know it's a good analog
for the Mexican analog for the mecha to
the memory but it's not a good analog
that nature doesn't do it that way how
things happen in a better way actually
because in a lot of weight I mean there
are a lot of different ways to survive
and thrive in particular environments
and it doesn't have to be one way it
could be like one like one way is the
best way but then there's like the
second like that's way you know in
chimps the biggest strongest males
aren't the only ones pass energy exactly
also the cute guys are sneaking it right
found it that's what I mean it's like
yeah it's right the big strong but
they're the second emails but these
little cute [ __ ] are sneaking
[ __ ] semen and
right and like you there like go on keep
this she quiet the girls like going yeah
I got that [ __ ] on film
yeah well it's like they even have the
same where I came from you know the same
thing I'm like even like cephalopods
like octopus and stuff like that like
yeah you have the big strongest male
like supposedly he you know saiyrs all
the next generation but you also have
the quote-unquote beta males that
pretend to be females to get close to
the females and the females are like you
see a lot of that your peak to you see a
lot of that you see what we're saying
and that works too yeah this is a Tom
and Jenny drunk I'll tell you what
finished on this subject we need to take
a break we'll come back on the next one
yeah we'll take a break in them we're
gonna come back I'll let's talk a little
bit about the Black Knight satellite
because yeah I just wrote a big article
about this I don't know much about this
one so listen this is kind of an
interesting topic even though it's
boiler alert I don't think if they like
that level but you know we'll get into
that all right but we will talk about
that after the break